time travel Shenanigans historical
whoopsies and a hard-headed inability to
believe in the Supernatural let's turn
back the clock and relive dial of
Destiny's biggest head scratchers
the film's opening flashback to Indy
being captured by the Nazis sees him
narrowly escape death thanks to some
seriously lucky breaks for starters
India is able to stop himself from being
hung thanks to a wayward bomb but oddly
enough that's not even the most
unbelievable thing that happens in this
opening rather it's Indy's plan to steal
a car so that he can hop onto a moving
train that makes absolutely zero sense
to steal the car Indy punches a guard
sitting in the driver's seat rolls the
body away and then assumes the driver's
role as high-ranking commanders get in
that's standard ending but in this
instance it's not like this car is
particularly far away from everyone else
soldiers can be seen loading stuff in
the background so it's pretty wild that
no one saw Indy punch the guard and get
in the driver's seat it's even more
bizarre when you realize that the
officer gets in the back seat literally
seconds after Indy knocks the guard out
how could those officers not see the
body of the Guard Indie knocked out or
for that matter how do they not see the
entire exchange take place the guard's
body only rolled a couple of feet away
so it's mind-blowing how Indie gets away
with this one Indy may have a knack for
quickly impersonating an enemy in a
pinch but this scene pushes the limits
while India is making his way up the
train to find the stolen knife artifact
his partner and friend basil Shaw has
been captured by the Nazis and is being
interrogated by the intimidating Colonel
Weber
although Weber tries to squeeze some
information out of Shaw through some
violent tactics he doesn't get much and
only learns the truth when Jurgen voller
appears to tell him that the Lance of
longinus or at least the tip of it
artifact is actually fake and that
baller has half of the dial of Destiny
in his possession Shaw is a little busy
escaping his restraints during this
conversation but he's only in the Next
Room and makes several reactions
suggesting that he can hear what they're
saying so why does he act so surprised
by all this information when he meets up
with any to talk about it when Indy
tells him that the artifact is fake it's
like he had no idea and he even acts
like he didn't know the dial was sitting
in the room next door despite hearing
them talking about it moments earlier
Shaw is definitely a bizarre character
for Indy to partner up with but this
takes things to a whole other level of
strange
speaking of the lands of longinus
although the Nazis have collected an
immense amount of Priceless artifacts
during their latest raid the most
notable artifact they find is
surprisingly fake it's something that
baffles Valor the rest of his Nazi
compatriots and even Indy so why was
this fake artifact stashed amongst all
the real ones it could be to trick
treasure Hunters into thinking they got
an item more valuable than the rest but
it seems like kind of a faulty tactic
since the Nazis just took everything
anyway it's never really explained why
there's just this one random fake
artifact stashed in this historic
Treasure Trove but it's likely that it's
just a plot contrivance the idea of the
lance being fake is really just an
excuse for Valor to introduce the dial
to Weber and the audience Hitler made
mistakes and with this I will correct
them all although valer is determined to
see his plan through to the very end he
makes some questionable choices that
show him just getting in his own way
namely his perplexing choice to not kill
Helena in Indy when he has the chance
there are multiple times throughout the
film where Indian Helena are basically
sitting ducks or captured by valer and
it's weird that he never just puts a
bullet in their head to stop their
pursuit of him
sure it would stop the movie in its
tracks but it would also solve nearly
all of his problems he even has a
trigger happy henchman who would love to
put Indy down however he never does and
it constantly backfires on him since
they always manage to be one step ahead
of it sure he does kind of need the
midpoint since he is following their
footsteps and needs some information
from them but once he gets it he just
should have ended things there even more
confusing is why Waller feels the need
to bring Indy with him as they head back
in time since that decision does nothing
but cause chaos throughout the finale
valer might have some deep knowledge as
a scientist and an historian but he
probably wishes he could go back in time
to get some more common sense as a
villain along with Teddy being hell and
his partner in crime he acts as the
group's youthful spark of energy and can
be a very useful pickpocket when needed
however he's unfortunately captured by
baller and his men and is stuck with
them after being handcuffed to one of
valer's goons while Teddy has surely
escaped situations like this before he's
in a pretty tough spot and comes up with
an escape plan that miraculously Works
yes it sort of makes sense that Teddy's
best option is to get the bad guy into
the river below the only thing is that
Teddy literally said he didn't know how
to swim earlier knowing that dropping
into a river doesn't feel like a
particularly ingenious plan especially
being tied to this hulking mass of a man
somehow though he's able to have enough
strength to breathe underwater and stay
calm enough to escape his restraints and
pinballer's Lackey underwater before
well swimming away it's an Escape Plan
that defies logic in multiple ways and
really shows that luck and plot armor
are on Teddy's side impressive kid
although dial Destiny might not see
Indie face his deadliest or most
physically demanding threats yet it
still doesn't go easy on him he's still
forced to be a part of some high-speed
chases deep sea Dives and high-flying
Chaos however it's clear that Indy is
certainly testing the concept of age
being just a number to put it bluntly
he's pretty old at the time of dial of
Destiny given that Indy is in his
mid-30s and Raiders of the Lost Ark
which takes place in 1936 he should be
roughly around 70 in dial of Destiny
since the film takes place in 1969.
some mileage while he is Indiana Jones
who has been through quite a lot in his
adventures eventually the years have to
catch up with the mileage right no one's
saying that Indy would be a frail old
man at this age or anything but it's
occasionally tough to believe that he
can physically handle everything he goes
through in the film Plus getting shot or
punched would certainly inflict more
damage or have more of an impact on him
than in his younger days yet Indie seems
just as capable as he's always been it's
not a deal breaker but it's yet another
element that just slightly messes with
your suspension of disbelief
I don't believe in magic at this point
maybe it's time to start believing in
some magic when Indy first hears about
the Dial's potential to send its users
back in time he doesn't believe that
it's real he constantly dismisses Shaw's
belief that the Nazis wanted to change
the course of history along with all the
other lore surrounding this secret power
within the dial he eventually comes to
believe in the Dial's power but it's
honestly weird that Indy had his doubts
from the start given what he's been
through in the past when you look at
what Indy has seen and dealt with in his
adventures it's surprising that he has
doubts about anything anymore he was
there when the Ark of the Covenant
melted faces with divine power and
watched the Holy Grail age a man to dust
in seconds for the crime of taking a
poorly chosen sip so the only thing that
should really surprise him these days is
that Marion keeps coming back in Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull he literally
discovered the existence of
interdimensional beings and saw what
potential alien life forms looked like
so is it really that out of the question
that this dial could hold some time
traveling capabilities apparently for
Indy it does it first and although
Indy's quest for knowledge over
Superstition has always been one of his
defining characteristics
knowledge
treasure but by this point in his life
hey maybe that mystical artifact the
Nazis are searching for is the real deal
with the dial being supposedly able to
send users back in time it's no wonder
that it's such a coveted artifact voller
is ready to put a bullet in anyone that
gets in his way of obtaining it and indy
is willing to put his life on the line
so that it doesn't fall into the wrong
hands however the dial makes for some
confusing rules and limitations on time
travel the explanation seems to be that
the antikythera uses existing fissures
in time to allow time travel being
thousands of years old the calculations
the device uses are also thousands of
years old when Indy and the others
finally use it they get hurled through
time to the Battle of Syracuse rather
than wartime Germany did baller simply
get the equation wrong and lead the
group down a bad path is Indy right that
Archimedes didn't account for tectonic
shifts in the Earth it seems like that
suggestion may be the truth but frankly
the film doesn't make it completely
clear what's right or wrong nobody's
gonna believe it when everyone gets
transported back to the time of
Archimedes there's an instant concern
about what could happen because of their
presence after all there are surely
drastic ramifications for a World War II
plane flying through the Skies of a
battle that took place over a thousand
years ago or a major figure like
Archimedes interacting with people from
Far Beyond his time right well it's
tough to say whether there are
consequences as the film doesn't explain
much of the impact of Indy's Antics
invading the past when Indian Helena
first discovered Archimedes grave they
notice his corpse holding a watch and
his tomb showing pictures of a beast
that looked like it had plane waves so
does this mean that the events that take
place were always meant to happen and be
a part of History it sure seems like it
but it's never really clarified plus it
doesn't help that the characters never
bring it up again or question if their
actions had any effect on history at all
although India is undoubtedly the hero
of this adventure he's not exactly seen
that way by everyone after ballerin is
lackeys kill some of the professors
University companions when they first
show up to retrieve the dial in the
attempts to call for help unfortunately
his efforts are interrupted by baller's
cohorts and the unfinished call ends up
making in the elite murder suspect
before Indy can even travel out of the
U.S he's considered a wanted man and
nearly gets recognized before Salah
steps in to save him however this
surprisingly isn't the case when Indy
returns when Indy reawakens in the
present there are no cops around ready
to cut them nor any signs that he's
still being pursued for murder
given that the police would still have
no reason to believe that someone killed
those people other than Indy it's a
little weird that Indy seems to suddenly
be getting off scot-free maybe Helena
was able to sneak Indie back undetected
or the police gave up because of lack of
evidence however it's incredibly strange
how no one talks about it in the film's
final moments in the mystery of whether
or not Indy is a wanted man will
continue or be left as a total platform
foreign